Oh, it's Botanicals Week.
Celebrating everything botanical,
flavours, spices
and edible floral displays.
So, Noel, have a taste of that.
I'm not tasting that.
It looks like it won first prize
at the Chelsea Flower Show.
Well, it's all edible.
-The whole thing?
-The whole thing.
Okay. [sighs]
What are you doing?
You're not supposed to eat the plate.
[Alison sighs]
Welcome to The Great British Baking Show.
It's not bad, got a nice crunch.
-Are you all right?
-I'm gonna eat the table next.
-[Noel] Now…
-Go, girl!
-…it's Botanicals Week.
-Dandelion syrup.
[Noel] And the bakers
spice up the signature…
-Lean on these buns.
-Yeah.
-Come on.
-[snores]
…are living on borrowed time
in the technical…
Out of sight, out of mind.
…and take on a blooming
ambitious showstopper.
This is crazy.
[Noel] Who will come up smelling of roses?
It's absolutely heavenly.
[Noel] And who will be rooted
out of the competition?
[clatters]
[Dan] Wrong thing to do.
[opening theme music playing]
-Week six, can't believe it.
-[Tasha] There's only seven of us.
It's a big change
going from nine to seven.
-Good luck.
-Good luck, mate. Enjoy.
Botanical Week is quite different.
I had to ask Lara what botanicals was
and then google it, but…
[exhales sharply]
Botanicals is like flavours
that have come from plants.
Like flowers and the roots or the barks.
It's not something
that I usually work with,
because you can't go
foraging really in London.
[Dana] Because we're closer
to the end, I'd like to get
at least a handshake,
come first in technical or Star Baker.
One of them, and I'll be happy.
[Noel and Alison chuckle]
Welcome to Botanicals Week, everybody.
Now, this is a chance for you to get your
botties out and show us what they can do.
For your botty signature challenge,
the judges would love you
to celebrate spice
by making a batch of 12
perfectly fragrant spiced buns.
You have two hours and 45 minutes
before Prue and Paul
want to see your buns.
Paul checked mine out this morning.
[Alison] I saw him.
-He was disappointed. [laughs]
-[Alison laughs]
-[Noel] On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake!
[Saku] Here we go.
I have made spiced buns at home,
but just gotta get 'em identical today.
Bread Week went well,
so I'm using what I know.
I forgot the egg. Hang on.
It's Botanicals Week,
and we're celebrating spice,
herbs and lots of floral hints.
In life, I'm spicy,
probably not in baking. [chuckles]
So the signature challenge
is 12 spiced buns.
Spice is the hero, so we want to taste it.
Don't want it to be too much.
I don't wanna offend them.
And you know what Paul is like,
they have to be absolutely identical.
It's about keeping it consistent.
To create 12 beautifully sweet
spiced sticky buns.
-Hello, Saku.
-Hello. Hello.
Tell us about your spiced buns.
I'm making Swedish cinnamon buns
with lots of cardamoms.
-Saku.
-[chuckles]
I'm not going to confuse you.
Well, I'm confused because I'm so used
to you bringing Sri Lanka into this.
Yes, cinnamon and cardamom from Sri Lanka.
This is an international affair.
Swedish bun
with Sri Lankan cinnamon and cardamom.
[Alison] For her take
on Swedish cinnamon buns,
Saku will add cardamom
to both the dough and cinnamon filling
before creating its intricate shape.
I swirl it and then, er,
shape it into a kind of little knot.
And they'll all be identical? Exactly?
I hope it will be identical. They will be.
-Good luck, Saku. Sounds delicious.
-Thank you.
[Noel] Good luck.
[Dan] Looking groovy.
[Alison] All the bakers
are making an enriched bread dough.
[Dana] It's got butter, so extra fat.
Kind of soften it, just makes it
a bit more flavourful.
[Noel] Adding spices at this stage will
not only boost the flavour of their cake…
[whispers] Smells nice.
…but also lend it an enticing colour…
[Dan] Saffron goes into the buns,
gives 'em a yellow summery colour.
That's all the spice in, so it's got
that gorgeous light brown colour to it.
[Noel] …or not.
That is disgusting.
-You're not putting this in.
-It's in there.
When you add mulled wine to egg,
it goes grey.
That is absolutely vile, babes.
Thank you. [laughs]
[Noel] They may currently be grey,
but Tasha's hoping her buns
will bring some festive cheer to the tent
with cinnamon, nutmeg
and cloves in her fillings.
And mulled wine in her egg wash and glaze
as well as her dough.
The mulled wine is the liquid
that goes into the dough?
So it replaces half the milk and water.
Quite a dangerous thing to do.
Thank you. [laughs]
Do you find that the dough
can be quite tight?
No comment.
[all laughing]
Paul, she is playing you at your own game.
-This is like poker.
-[all laughing]
I'm meant to say no comment, not you.
[all laughing]
[Alison] While Tasha tackles Christmas…
"The flavours are always nice."
Famous last words.
…Matty's embracing Easter.
[Matty] I'm making a spiced hot cross bun.
I've done a practice,
but they weren't very good.
But I think I was trying to get 'em done
before the West Ham game.
[Alison] To ensure his flavours
hit the back of the net,
as the only baker not to use a filling,
Matty's packing his dough
with cinnamon, nutmeg, and ginger,
along with dried fruits
he soaked in ginger rum.
Hot cross buns, recently, the bought ones,
have got worse and worse.
Don't hold back, Prue.
You need to show the nation
what a good hot cross bun can be.
Don't put that pressure on me. [laughs]
-Look forward to this.
-Thanks.
-[Noel] Good luck.
-Thank you.
The nation are dependent.
I don't even like hot cross buns.
[Josh] Looks lovely. I'm happy.
[Cristy] Looking for it to be
soft and smooth and stretchy.
Ready for its first prove.
[Matty] Bit tacky, but…
Paul said to me in the technical
of Bread Week it's underproved.
You don't want to be told
the same negative thing twice.
-[Dan] Flying.
-[Saku] Here we go.
-[Matty] In the drawer.
-[Noel] With their dough rising…
-Do you want me to open it?
-No.
[laughing]
I don't want to be
responsible for lack of rise.
-[laughs]
-…the bakers can turn to their fillings.
[Cristy] This is the cinnamon.
I know they like a punchy flavour.
I hope I get it just right.
[Noel] As well as incorporating cinnamon
into her pecan filling and dough,
Cristy is also adding it to her glaze,
which she'll drizzle on with maple syrup.
[Alison] This is gonna be good.
Can I say something?
-Go on.
-Star Baker, handshake.
-No tears in this tent today.
-What the hell.
[Alison] Let's be honest.
We gotta see how these go.
Go, girl!
-[laughter]
-[Cristy] Thank you.
[Alison] While Cristy
is supersizing her spice…
[Cristy] It needs more cinnamon.
[Alison] …Dana is dialling hers down.
Last time I used cardamom,
you said it was medicinal.
So I'm reining it back a bit.
How are you bringing
these flavours into the bun?
The dough is plain,
the cardamom comes in the filling.
[Alison] With no flavouring in her dough,
Dana is relying on the other elements
to pack a punch.
She's using cardamom, pistachio
and orange in her fillings,
glazes and toppings.
And to finish, she'll sprinkle rose petals
on her knotted creations.
Interesting shape, lovely flavours.
I think it sounds really delicious.
It's about uniformity
and getting the flavours through.
And getting
the cardamom levels just right.
Erm… Yes.
[Prue and Paul laughing]
Just a tiny bit of maple,
I don't want it to be oversweet.
[Noel] Ensuring the perfect balance…
More cardamom.
…with the spices dominant
but not overwhelming…
Just fine-tuning.
…becomes even trickier
when they're paired
with other strong flavours.
'Cause it's gonna be nice and spiced,
I wanted something to cut through that.
So I'll inject a lemon curd into the buns.
[Noel] In addition
to his tangy lemon curd filling,
Josh is giving his cinnamon buns
a further fruity frisson
with fresh and dried blueberries.
Are we going to think
this is a lemon and blueberry bun,
or will we think this a spiced bun?
The dried ones, I've soaked
in a cinnamon tea overnight.
Does it stop the blueberry
being a blueberry?
-[hesitates] No, it still holds the taste.
-Paul's worried about blueberries, I see.
[Paul] Good luck.
[Alison] Dan is also adding
fruity flavours to his spiced buns.
[Dan] Lemon, got some orange,
I'm gonna top it with figs.
These are the type of buns
you'd like to eat outside a Greek taverna
with a lovely little mug of espresso.
[Alison] To capture
the spirit of the Aegean
as well as his figs and citrus fruits,
Dan will use saffron,
cinnamon and star anise
in his Chelsea bun-style creations.
-Can't go wrong with buns, can you?
-No. No, hopefully not.
I probably can. But, erm, we shall see.
I feel like… [laughs]
-So sorry.
-[Noel] Who's this?
It's my stalker. Don't worry.
The dame can appear anywhere.
It's like Rentaghost.
-She can just pop up anywhere.
-Yeah.
When I wake up in the morning,
-she's at the end of my bed.
-Is she? That's… quite scary.
-That sounded weird.
-Pretty weird.
It's better than Paul being there.
[laughing]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
It's quite hot in there.
I don't want them to overprove.
[Noel] The extra fat in an enriched dough,
as well as the addition of the fruit
and spices, can mean a slower rise.
Let me just check.
[Noel] But if the bakers remove
their dough before it's fully proved…
-[Dana] I've got five more minutes.
-Please prove.
[Noel] …they risk a tight texture
in their finished buns.
It's got another prove yet anyway,
so we'll go with it.
Say got a bit longer.
He always says it's not proved.
-Yeah.
-Just do it a bit longer.
-Watch him say it's overproved this week.
-Oh, don't say that.
If he says that, I'll look the other way.
-[both laugh]
-[Cristy] I'm just gonna get it out.
[Josh] It's huge.
Pretty good. Erm, it's nice and proved.
[Saku] Perfect.
[Josh] I'm gonna mix in this filling.
I don't think blueberry
is that strong a fruit.
It's just a nice blend.
Need to put a very thin layer.
I hope Paul loves these nuts.
These fine nuts. [chuckles]
[Matty] If I can make sure
that they're even weight,
it should mean they end up
looking somewhat the same.
[Alison] The judges are expecting
12 identical spiced buns.
It's thinner on one end. So annoying.
[Alison] But the more complicated
the shape of the buns…
I'm cutting into
12 equal pieces, then twisting.
…the trickier that will be to achieve.
[Dana] Pinch it and roll.
One done. It looks quite pretty.
[Saku] Silly me, measured in inches
and then cut into centimetres.
[Tasha] These are quite big.
[Cristy] I think they're gonna go, waah,
like Yorkshire puddings.
Looks identical in shape, isn't it?
Happy, happy, happy.
[Dan] A couple are a bit higher
than the others,
but second prove,
they'll start joining together.
I'm happy with them.
They look identical, apart from that one.
I'm hoping we'll have twins
and not sisters.
[Saku] Ready, in.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
[Dan] Prove is definitely done.
I think they look all right.
I'm putting an egg wash,
so it'll get nice and brown when baked.
It's like this grey sludge.
Don't know if this is good,
it's very gloopy.
The figs are nice on top.
I'll baste it in honey and butter.
Turns into jam.
We're going in.
[Josh] 195, 20 minutes.
Twelve minutes, 200.
They're looking quite nice.
Yeah, nice and golden in colour.
[Dana] Little bit longer.
Few more minutes.
[exhales]
They look beautiful. Look! Are you happy?
I am happy.
You don't look happy.
But, you know, it's sticking out.
Oh, it's all right. It's fine.
-Lean on these buns.
-Yeah.
-[snores and chuckles]
-Lean on these buns. Have a little sleep.
[chuckles] Let me rub your head.
I don't think the cross has worked.
It's really faint.
-Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
-Oh, flippin' heck.
Ten minutes to get your buns out the oven.
[Matty] I am quite impressed
[sighs]
[Dana] Not identical at all.
[Josh] All look very even.
[Saku] Oh, these are not identical.
-[Tasha] Pretty good.
-Nice and hollow.
I'm going to give it a nice glaze,
[Dan] Quite pleased with that colour.
Maybe they're not quite identical.
[Josh] Lemon curd.
[Tasha] I've got my mulled wine glaze
and it will kind of melt into the pastry.
And it's not grey. [chuckles]
Glaze on. Want to get it in
all my nooks and crannies.
Lovely bakers, you have one minute left.
[Matty] Finishing touches,
sprinkle some cinnamon.
I've never done that before,
let's see how that turns out.
[Tasha] A bit of glitter.
[Josh] I wanted the two-tone,
lemon and blueberry.
[Dan] So let's get 'em on then.
[Dana] Sprinkling some rose petals.
After all, it is Botanical Week.
[Saku] Oh, my word. Two more to go,
not enough space.
-[chuckles]
-Don't think it's gonna fit on my tray.
I hope they live up
to everyone's expectations.
[Dana] Ugh, mine are all misshapen.
Bakers, your time is up.
[in Jamaican accent]
Step away from your buns.
-Stop.
-[exhales]
[Alison in normal accent] Come on.
Group hug.
-[Alison laughing]
-[indistinct chatter]
I don't want anyone to touch me.
[Alison] You smashed it, guys, well done.
[Noel] The bakers' spiced buns
will now be judged by Paul and Prue.
Hello, Tasha.
-Hello.
-Hello, Tasha.
I like the colour, it's unusual.
It's festive.
I think, if anything, they're a bit big.
[Paul] But there's a lot
of consistency there, which I like.
Wow, that's quite an open structure.
-Surprising.
-Worth the risk. [chuckles]
It's Christmas.
-Phew.
-[Prue] I love the flavour.
I like the texture.
It is beautifully balanced
between all the flavours.
You created something
that's pleasant in the mouth.
-Well done.
-Terrific.
-Thank you.
-Thanks.
[exhales]
I love the shine.
I think they look
really tempting and delicious.
-But they're uneven.
-[Paul] Dramatically uneven.
You do get the saffron,
the spices coming through
and at a nice level.
It's not overpowering.
My only big issue
is the consistency in this shape…
-[Dan] Yeah.
-…and size.
What I think is the crowning glory
is the fresh figs on top.
-[Dan] Yeah.
-That's a piece of genius.
-Lovely.
-Works well.
-Thank you.
-That's great.
Thank you. Nice One.
The issue is consistency or inconsistency
of the shape and colour.
There's not two alike. It's a shame.
-[Prue] Not a lot of cardamom.
-Okay.
-You get the orange and pistachio.
-[Paul] Cardamom, barely getting that.
Actually get more rose.
-Do you?
-Yeah.
We'll change the title of it.
They're rose buns.
-Yes.
-There we go.
-Thank you.
-[Alison and Dana] Thank you.
They look very nice. I like the colour.
A bit of an unusual size difference.
-My maths went wrong.
-Don't you work in accountancy?
-Shh.
-[all laughing]
I will lose my job now.
-Erm, the knot works quite nicely.
-[Prue] Yes.
Yes, I love the twisting. It's lovely.
Quite a tight texture.
[Prue] Mmm.
Your balance of cardamom is just lovely.
The flavour combination
between the cardamom and the cinnamon
is absolutely spot on.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Well, they look very unusual.
Like a cartoon character with the eyes.
"Look into my eyes."
Nice colour. It's got a lovely colour.
You don't get the blueberry.
The blueberry's become a carrier
for the cinnamon.
I actually like it.
It reminds me of an iced bun
with the lemon running through it.
Iced buns are one of my favourite things.
I do think the bread is beautiful.
The glaze is beautiful.
I like the look of 'em.
-Wonderful, thank you.
-It's pretty good bun.
-I think they're pretty consistent, these.
-[exhales]
Wow, they look impressive inside,
I'll tell you that now.
-Oh, good.
-[Paul] To get that even all the way.
You've rolled the dough thin,
so you get a lot of filling.
And I like that.
Flavour is lovely.
Maple syrup's there, it's not too sweet.
-Nice.
-[Paul] Delicious.
Absolutely delicious,
and I'm trying not to eat any more.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Well done.
I think they look lovely and shiny.
They're very even. You managed the cross.
Cross looks good. I do like the colour,
some nice consistency. What is it again?
-Hot cross. Yeah.
-Hot cross bun.
-I'll judge you as a hot cross bun.
-If it's better, it's a spiced bun.
[all laugh]
Right answer.
-[Paul] It's too dense.
-Okay.
[Paul] I've had cakes that are more open.
It's underproved.
More proving would've opened that up.
Not getting the ginger.
There's not enough of it.
You need more fruit.
-If you're gonna put fruit, put fruit.
-[Matty] Yeah.
I still think it's very delicious.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Cheers.
Ah, thanks, Matty.
I told you to prove it a bit longer,
didn't I?
-You did. [laughs]
-Yeah.
I think I impressed Prue
a little bit more than Paul.
I'm team Prue for now. [laughs]
I'm happy that the flavours worked.
Yeah, it's Christmas in a bun.
Could've gone better, but it's fine.
Still got the technical.
So, hopefully I can
just smash that one out.
[screeching]
[Alison] The bakers could practise
spicy signature bakes,
but the technical challenge is a mystery.
It's time for your technical challenge.
This one has been set
for you by the delightful Prue.
-Prue, any words of wisdom?
-Yes.
Be bold with the botanicals.
-I found that moving.
-Aw.
-You all right?
-Yeah, I am.
Talking of moving, it's time for you guys
to move on out. Thank you.
-We'll miss you, guys.
-We are.
Prue would like you to make
a beautifully decorated
lemon and thyme drizzle cake.
They're looking for a light moist sponge
that is soaked with lemon and thyme syrup
and a sprinkling of crystallised
lemon and thyme.
-How much time have we got?
-An hour and 30.
[Alison] On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
Oh, my God. Right.
Interesting cake. [laughs]
I imagine it's gonna take a bit of time.
No pun intended.
This challenge is right up your street,
you've come as a lemon.
[both laugh]
I just wanna point out at this moment
in time that you've come as thyme.
[laughing]
Prue, tell us about
your lemon and thyme drizzle cake.
[Prue] It is just a cream sponge
baked in a fancy tin,
but the difference is
it has a lot of thyme in it.
What I'm worried about most is, I think,
they won't put enough in it.
Only a bit
and it'll just be a lemon drizzle cake.
[Paul] They've got the tin.
If they don't grease it properly, Paul,
as you know that cake will stick.
Come on, I'm dribbling now, I need a bite.
My goodness, that's a fair slice.
-[Paul] That big enough?
-Yes.
Ooh, yeah.
This is moist from the drizzle.
The lemon and thyme
work beautifully together.
-It's absolutely lovely.
-Hmm.
For me,
it'll come down to flavour and balance
between the thyme and lemon.
Are they gonna get it right?
Gotta have lots of thyme.
What's ironic is we've only given
them an hour and a half.
[laughs] I know.
Instruction number one,
"Make the cake mixture."
Fabulous.
It's been so long
since I've made a sponge cake.
I haven't made one in yonks.
I'm creaming the butter
and the sugar together, adding the lemon.
[Tasha] Self-raising flour.
[Dana] Get that mixed in on a low speed.
[Cristy] This'll be enough.
[Saku] It's a light, fluffy sponge.
-[Alison] You ever made one before?
-I've made lemon drizzle cake.
-You have?
-But not with thyme.
-You know?
-Yeah.
-Thyme for roast, not a cake.
-It's in food. Not normally in a bake.
Maybe it will taste like
roast dinner. [laughs]
[Alison chuckles]
They told us how much lemon to use,
but not how much thyme to use.
What I would normally do
is just add only a little.
Baker's instinct. Prue said, "Be bold."
Prue, I'm with you, sister.
Try and get the thyme
really in there, you know?
[Josh] Couple of heaped tablespoons.
I did not measure the amount of thyme
I was putting in. Risky.
It does smell strong.
I can't smell anything. Bit more thyme.
Just preparing the cake tin
with some butter, so it doesn't stick.
It's hard to do.
There's a risk of things catching,
so you want it to come out.
[Josh] I'm gonna give it a dusting
with some flour.
[Dana] I've put more thyme in.
You can see all the green specks,
so I'm hoping it'll be fine.
[Matty] Slap it down
so it gets into all those crevices.
[Cristy] Get it in.
-Has she been kind with the method?
-No.
[Alison] Not really. Oh.
-Just, "Bake." Gosh!
-Just bake it.
-[timers beeping]
-[indistinct chatter]
It's gonna take a while in the oven.
It's a big cake. Definitely 40 minutes.
I'm gonna set a timer for 40 minutes.
[beeping]
[sighs heavily]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
[Noel hums circus song]
-Oh, God.
-[Matty] Need to get a move on.
"Make the lemon and thyme syrup."
Juice of two lemons,
sugar and thyme, right.
This is where Prue also said, "Be bold."
I'm gonna give her thyme.
-[Josh] I'll let that infuse.
-[Matty] That's ready to rock and roll.
[Dan] Four, "We crystallise the lemon peel
and thyme."
There's an egg white in it?
Egg white, dip the thyme leaves in
and covering it all in sugar.
Why is there an egg white in it?
It's crystallised.
I'm gonna put sugar on to it
and then get it to dry out.
[Saku sighs]
I haven't a clue
if I'm doing this the right way.
-What the hell is this?
-What is that?
[chuckling]
[Matty] Somehow it's gonna crystallise.
Is that in the recipe?
Out of sight, out of mind.
-[Noel] Saku.
-[Saku] Yes.
How many keepy-uppies
can you do with a lemon?
-None. None.
-[Noel] None?
Look, one, boom.
-[Saku grunts]
-[all laugh]
-[Saku] Any good?
-Amazing.
You see?
Do you reckon I could hit one
of those saucepans with this lemon?
[Saku] No.
[glass shatters]
-[laughs]
-[Noel blows raspberry]
[Noel] It's fine, nothing broke.
[Noel laughs]
Never a dull moment in here.
[both] Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
[softly] My goodness me.
[Tasha] I'm nervous. I'm not doing it.
[Josh] Skewer's coming out clean, so…
Just gonna go for it.
[Saku] I hope it is ready.
Smells nice. Can't smell any thyme, but…
[chuckles]
It's definitely baked.
Ah! Okay, yeah, it's coming out.
A bit overdone,
but it's better to overbake it
and then cover any problems
with the syrup.
The problem is turning it upside down.
Oh, I'm so scared.
[Tasha] Flipping heck.
[grunts softly]
[Josh] Worst thing
would be for it not to come out.
Phew. [chuckles]
[Saku sighs]
Bad, bad, bad, really bad.
[Dana] Trying to find the good side.
It looks okay. It's come out neat.
[Tasha, nervously] Ah!
The bottom is ugly.
Oh, flipping heck.
[in deep voice]
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[exhales]
[softly] Come on, Josh. Come on.
Number five, "Soak the cake with syrup."
Gonna give it little holes.
Just get that in.
There's not much dripping off
so it is actually going in.
[Tasha] Oh, that smells like thyme.
I think. Maybe too much.
Made my icing.
[Saku] Drizzling consistency.
[Dan] Could've done with it being thicker.
[Tasha] Control, control.
I don't know
what it's supposed to look like.
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
-[Dan] Last bit.
-Let's make this look pretty.
Lemon and thyme.
[Saku] Oh, come on.
[Matty] Gonna use this very sparingly.
[Cristy] Gonna try and make it look nice.
[Tasha] Just not that pretty.
That's fine.
[Dana] Quite rustic.
That seems to be my kind of thing.
Okay, bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your lemon and thyme
drizzle cakes up to the gingham table
and place them behind your pictures.
[Saku] My word, it was a race.
[Noel] It's judgement time for the bakers'
lemon and thyme drizzle cakes.
[exhales]
Prue and Paul are looking for a light,
moist, aromatic cake
decorated with glacé icing
and crystallised lemon and thyme.
And they have no idea whose is whose.
Interesting array.
The definition on this one
is pretty good. It's got a strong colour.
Icing could've been a little thicker
or not allowed to run right off.
Crystallising looks okay.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-[Prue] There's a lot of drizzle.
[Paul] Texture's good, very light.
It's not got enough thyme in it.
[Paul] Moving on, little bit weird
with the colouring on this one.
See how light, dark,
it's like it hasn't been mixed properly.
Quite an open-looking cake.
[Prue] Far more lemon than thyme.
Which I don't mind.
I quite like the sharpness of the lemon
-against the hint of thyme.
-[Prue] Yeah.
I think I'd have put a little bit more
crystallised lemon and thyme on top.
-But it's very nice.
-[Paul] Yeah, it is.
[Prue] I like the decoration of this.
This is a thicker icing.
There's a few little marks here.
Like it's caught.
-[Prue] It's stuck.
-Half the cake's on the mould.
I can tell you now
there's not enough thyme in there.
[Paul] Not a lot of lemon or thyme.
[Prue] I think that texture's
a bit coarse too.
[Paul] A bit dark, this one.
-It's almost overflowed on the top.
-[Prue] Overflowed.
And I really think
the icing is a bit clumsy.
-[Paul] Getting the thyme and the lemon.
-[Prue] Lot more thyme.
It's slightly overbaked.
The icing is neat, into the grooves.
It's quite clever because the baker
has put thyme in one
-and lemon in the other. It's very neat.
-[Paul] Yeah.
Hmm, definitely getting the thyme
and the lemon.
Nice balance.
I think it's very good.
[Paul] Moving on, bit irregular on colour.
-[Prue] Hmm.
-Darker on one side than on another.
It's broken a bit here in the mould.
The lemon isn't properly crystallised.
-It's very raw.
-[Paul] No.
-I got more thyme than lemon.
-[Prue] Mmm.
[Paul] Last one. I like the look of this.
Pretty neat on the baking as well.
I like the way the icing is confined
to small ribbons down the runnels.
I can see the thyme, but I can't taste it.
[both] It could have a bit more.
The lemon's tangy enough
and the bake's good.
[Alison] The lemon and thyme drizzle cakes
will now be ranked
from last to first place.
In seventh, place we have this one. Tasha.
Bit clumsy on the icing,
and you had trouble with it
getting out of the tin, didn't you?
In sixth spot, we have this one.
This is very irregular with the colours.
Inside, too pale.
You had problems with it
sticking to the tin or was it the bake?
-No, I dunno. [chuckles]
-Hmm.
[Noel] Saku is in fifth place,
Matty is fourth, and Dan comes third.
In second, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Very nice, Josh.
I like the icing, I like the decoration,
I love the colour.
Needed a little more thyme,
but it's a nice one.
Which means…
-[Cristy chuckling]
-[Prue] Cristy. [chuckles]
I loved your decoration,
it's very elegant.
Lots of thyme, lots of lemon, perfect.
-[Cristy] Thank you.
-[Saku] Well done.
[Josh] Well done.
Well done, bakers. You've done so well.
Go home, have a little rest, and we'll see
you tomorrow for the showstopper.
[Noel] Well done, kids.
I genuinely never thought
I'd get first in the technical.
So, yeah, I'm over the moon.
[Dana] I was hoping for a good technical,
but second to last is not last.
Ugh! That was really bad.
Yeah, I can't lie.
I feel a bit sick about tomorrow.
I'm not ready to go home.
It's Botanicals Week.
So, did anybody really shine?
I think Cristy's in a very strong position
for Star Baker again this week.
What about Tasha?
[Prue] She did not do a good technical,
-but a tremendously good signature.
-She did.
Josh is doing quite well.
[Paul] Josh is doing all right
which puts him in line with Cristy,
but the likes of Dana, Matty,
are in worse trouble than the rest.
Matty, why did he do
so bad in the signature?
-A bit boring.
-Not enough fruit in it.
-Okay.
-[Paul] I didn't like Dana's signature.
The shapes were wrong.
We wanted consistency and didn't get it.
You've gotta look at all of it.
Texture, appearance, flavour,
technical prowess.
Any mistakes, you could go home.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your showstopper challenge.
The judges would like you to bake
a beautiful and imaginative
floral dessert.
You can choose any style of dessert,
but it must include
a significant baked element.
And you should celebrate florals
though your flavours and design.
-Floral really is the key word.
-It is.
Something you could serve at a picnic
or wear as a headdress at Glastonbury.
-You have four and a half hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
-[in Jamaican accent] Bake!
Experimenting with different
floral flavours, not my comfort zone.
Anything that I can mess up on,
I tend to stay clear.
When you put elderflower in,
it sounds quite, like, potion-y.
You know what I mean? Harry Potter.
So we're asking the bakers
for a layered dessert.
[Paul] We're talking jellies, ganaches,
bavarois, mousse, biscuits,
anything they wish.
Want it all to be
beautifully holding together.
[sighs] It's stressful.
The overall flavour is floral.
The trouble with flowers
is one second there's not enough flavour,
and then you go over the top
and then they taste like soap.
Dandelion syrup.
[Paul] It should taste incredible,
and, of course, look like a showstopper.
-Hello.
-Good morning.
-Tell us about your showstopper.
-A wildflower meadow theme,
and then I'm doing
a opera style floral dessert.
When you say opera,
how many layers are you using, seven?
Four layers of joconde.
So it's opera style.
Right. Are you using chocolate at the top?
No, I'm putting, erm, meadowsweet butter--
-When you say opera…
-It's a layered dessert.
Yeah. That's better.
[Alison] Dan's wildflower meadow
layered dessert
will include joconde sponges,
flavoured with elderflower,
a dandelion jelly pond, with choux swans,
and meadowsweet buttercream.
Meadowsweet, I've never heard of that.
[Dan] It's a local foraged plant.
-Grows around bogs, marshes.
-[Prue] You made this?
[Dan] Yeah.
Oh, it's recognisable.
Yeah, it is.
-Like cat pee.
-Yeah, that's the one.
-[laughs]
-I'm very impressed
-that you know what cat pee tastes like.
-[laughs]
[Alison] Matty's taking
his inspiration not from wildlife…
I've got one of those shot things.
Why didn't I bring it?
…but nightlife.
More of a drink, innit?
When you put elderflower in prosecco,
with some blackberries in it,
it's a real masculine drink.
People look scared
when you're drinking it.
[laughs] "I'll leave him alone."
[Noel] Taking his cue
from his favourite summer tipple,
Matty's adding elderflower
into nearly every element of his dessert,
including his blackberry mousse,
lemon crêmeux, génoise sponge
and blackberry mirror glaze.
-Is it true about blackberries?
-Being?
The blacker the berry,
the sweeter the juice, is it true?
[Matty chuckles]
Is it true?
[laughing]
You tell me.
[both laughing]
It's true.
[Noel] Whatever complementary flavours
the bakers are using…
[Saku] I'm making cheesecake base
with ginger biscuit.
[Noel] …their florals
need to be the star of the show.
[Saku] Floral flavours are subtle,
so I will use more hibiscus
to bring hibiscus flavour.
Want to get that tangy thing.
[Alison] Hibiscus will flavour
the mousse and buttercream
of Saku's Earl Grey cheesecake,
which will sit on a ginger biscuit base,
and be topped
with an intricate 3D jelly flower.
[Saku] I'm worried about the jelly art.
-I don't have artistic skills.
-You say that…
-You are artistic. Baking's art.
-Thank you.
Are you artistic? Of course, you are.
Who's your favourite artist?
Do you know Banksy?
-Does all--
-Yes, the one who is painting buildings.
He sent me a letter.
-Really?
-[Noel] Hmm.
-Are you joking?
-It just said "Stop" in it. Just "Stop."
[both laughing]
[Alison] One baker who doesn't know when
to curb their artistic ambitions is Tasha.
-Hello, Tash.
-Hi, Tash.
Good Morning.
Tell us all about your floral showstopper.
I'm going to be signing
because I don't feel confident
with pronouncing a few words in my recipe.
Okay.
So overall, within the elements,
I've got ten layers.
-[Prue] Ten layers.
-Ten.
[Prue] That's a bit ambitious.
Okay, here we go.
[Noel] Amongst Tasha's ten layers
will be a palet Breton biscuit,
a bavarois, two sponges,
three different jellies,
and a ruby chocolate mousse.
All flavoured with hibiscus
or elderflower,
these will be wrapped
in a hibiscus joconde sponge
and topped with jelly art.
Tasha, this is crazy.
Have you practised this?
Yeah, I've practised it twice.
If you pull it off,
it'll be fantastic.
-Thank you.
-I'm looking forward to this. Thank you.
[gasps]
I'm thinking
maybe I should drop something?
No, no, I'm not going to drop anything.
[Noel] Amongst their layers
must be a substantial baked element.
[Dan] Gonna rattle through
four joconde sponges.
[Noel] The bakers won't be able to begin
assembling their spectacular showstoppers…
Oh, come on, Josh.
…until their sponges
and biscuits are baked
and completely cool.
It's like the Baking Olympics today.
Trying to get
the ginger biscuit base sorted.
This is a hibiscus joconde that will be
spread over the elderflower design.
These are going in.
[oven beeps]
[Dana] That's good and spongy.
I'm happy with that.
[Josh] This is a really nice,
light trifle sponge.
I am doing a russe, like Charlotte russe.
It'll have sponge fingers on the outside,
and two sponge layers in the actual cake.
[Alison] As well as his sponges,
Josh's russe will contain a compote,
jellies and two bavarois,
flavoured with combinations
of raspberry, rhubarb and hibiscus.
Hibiscus is a flower
that I used to grow with my nan.
We used to do competitions.
We had hibiscus plants in conservatories,
we'd see who'd grow
the most hibiscus flowers.
Erm, you know, she'd get up to, like,
12 or 15 all at once. It's amazing.
[Alison] Dana's also using hibiscus,
but is pairing it
with floral powerhouse, rose.
[Dana] Rose has a strong taste to it.
I want the full-on flavour,
don't want any criticism
that they can't taste the components.
[Alison] Rose will feature
in her raspberry bavarois,
and white chocolate mousse,
which she'll complement
with a hibiscus jelly and coconut sponge.
Her finished dessert will sit inside
an ambitious sugar work box.
I am just layering this up
with edible flowers,
and then I'm putting isomalt over the top.
-[Noel] I like this.
-Do ya?
Yeah. I went out with a girl who put
flowers in resin. Reminds me of that.
That's the inspiration I had.
You see so many videos
on TikTok of it all going through.
So are you endlessly watching baking?
I start of watching baking stuff,
and somehow I've ended up watching, like,
shark attacks
or something like that. [laughing]
-I get loads of sharks.
-Do you?
-What is it about us that they went…
-What is it?
-…"They'd love shark attacks."
-[laughs] Yeah.
[Noel] One baker who could be heading
into deep water is Cristy
who's the only one to use
an intricate mould for her dessert.
[Cristy] So this is my mould.
It's risky 'cause it's very textured.
If I get it right, the payoff
I think will be nice. It's so effective.
[Noel] Cristy's moulded entremets
will contain lemon
and elderflower génoise sponge,
crème diplomat and two jellies,
strawberry and elderflower
and rhubarb and basil,
all encased
in a white chocolate ganache.
-White chocolate?
-Yeah.
Does it work? Do you look worried?
[chuckles]
It's quite warm today.
-It's really hot.
-You're using white chocolate ganache…
-Yeah.
-…moulded on the top.
If you get that chocolate ganache
out of the mould intact,
it'll look very pretty. Sounds good.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
[Alison] Good luck.
Bakers, you are halfway
through this "mammooth" challenge.
[Dan] Beautiful. No messing around.
[Tasha sighs]
[Matty] Let me check.
[Saku] I'll take it out. Looks all right.
Sponge fingers.
Yeah, they're good. Very good.
[Dan] Ow!
[tray clatters]
[Tasha] Oh, my God. [sighs]
[clatters]
[Dan] Wrong thing to do.
[Saku] Going to the fridge.
[Alison] With their
baked elements cooling…
[Matty] If it's tough, it's game over.
[Alison] …or being remade…
[Dan] I love making things twice.
That was my back-up cake,
so we're okay.
[Alison] …the bakers can finish
other elements of their dessert.
I've got my strawberry jelly started.
[Noel] Whether they're making jellies…
[Dan] My pond jelly
needs two gelatine leaves.
-[Noel] …mousses…
-[Saku] Hibiscus mousse.
-It needs lots of setting.
-[Noel] …or custards…
[Matty] This is the elderflower crémeux.
[Noel] …the amount of setting agent
will be crucial to ensure
a melt-in-the-mouth texture
and clearly defined layers.
Just mixed in my gelatine.
Don't want it to taste
unpleasant like rubber.
It could act as a bouncy ball.
[Dana] Some layers will be
looser than others,
but I want everything, when you
cut into it, nothing's oozing out.
I have no space.
I think you need seven benches
with all these ingredients.
What's going on?
Why create something so elaborate?
I'm the person I shout at
when I watch it on TV.
[Alison laughing]
As we were.
-[clattering]
-I might do another one.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
[sighs]
I'm trying not to think about the time.
[Dana] Start building.
Supposed to look like an entremets,
with layers and a lot of setting.
[Alison] Building floral masterpieces…
[Cristy] I need a really thin layer.
[Tasha] Ah, sugar.
[Josh] Right, happy with that.
[Alison] …will require
expert use of the fridge and freezer.
Might have to break this mould.
It's just set so firm.
[Noel] Too long at low temperatures
and their delicate sponges could dry out.
It's frozen solid. [laughs]
[Noel] But not long enough time chilling
and their jellies and creams
could fail to set,
resulting in a sloppy mess.
[Dan] I don't want to make a mess.
[Tasha] Just basically leaked.
-[Noel] That looks amazing.
-Yes, well…
[Noel] What'll you do with that?
Put it in the freezer?
You just pop that baby in the freezer.
Not a baby.
No one puts Baby in the freezer. [laughs]
It's a joke for Patrick Swayze fans.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Just half an hour.
[sighing] Oh, man…
Half an hour hopefully might just make it.
[Dana sighs] Right. Next step.
Fab.
Nice and even layers.
[Matty] It's set.
I could leave it in for longer.
I don't know why I'm not.
[Tasha] Could you
hold it steady while I peel…
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
I need to peel this,
jelly basically leaked.
It's gonna crack. [sighs]
Got my cream sorted for my choux buns.
This is the cooled down mirror glaze.
So it covers it a bit better.
I don't know if it's set… enough.
I can feel something not good.
-[Noel] Really?
-[exhales]
Breathe. Trust your instincts.
-I sound like Obi-Wan now. I'm Yoda.
-It is lifting off.
[mimics Yoda] Hmm,
trust your instincts, young Jedi.
Oh! It's broken.
-It's broken?
-It's broken.
-[Noel] You can fix that.
-I'm gonna… No.
It's broken everywhere.
Oh, my gosh. I'm gonna have to redo it.
I'm gonna literally freeze it
and remake it. I'm just gonna have to.
Oh, I'm gonna cry my eyes out.
Okay, just breathe.
[freezer door shuts]
-Oh, bless her.
-Babes, don't worry.
[sobs]
-Babe, you've got Star Baker. Hello?
-I just…
-I'm really hot.
-I know.
All right. You go… Cool down, cool down.
[Cristy] I'm really upset. [sniffles]
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
[Cristy] I'll be all right. [sighs]
[sobs] Oh.
-Need any help?
-No, I'm all right. Thank you, Dan.
I'm fine, I'm fine. [sniffles]
[Saku] Now the next nervous task
is the jelly domes.
I'm gonna do my jelly art in these.
They're crystallisation dishes
from the chemistry lab.
[Saku] I'm super nervous for this.
[exhales]
Choux swans haven't turned out
as choux swans unfortunately.
[sighs] Come on. [sniffles]
Oh, it's wobbling just like jelly. [gasps]
I don't know if it's right.
Something might be right with the mixture.
Oh, my gosh, I can't even look at that.
When I did this in practice,
it collapsed. [gasps]
[Tasha] Screwed up the first jelly,
need to do another.
[Matty] Which is not good.
Wouldn't imagine I'd be talking to you
while you make delicate pink rose flowers.
No, at the turn of the year,
I didn't think this would be a thing.
[Dan] Nothing's gonna set.
It's just not… It's just too…
It's just too, erm… Oh.
-I'm trying to think of this gap.
-Is that stuck on already?
-[Dana] Oh. Now it's cracked.
-Yeah.
-[gasps]
-Holy mackerel!
Oh, my God.
[Cristy] I'm gonna take the top off.
This is such a disaster.
Oh.
-[Dan] How long have we got?
-[both] Bakers.
You have five minutes left.
[Dan] Gotta dig deep now, gear six.
[Josh] Oh, my goodness me, perfection.
Can't have 'em eat this.
[sniffles] They can't.
[Josh] Oh, right.
I'm gonna slide it. [chuckles nervously]
Gentle, gentle movements, yeah.
This is where you could do
with being artistic and I am far from.
[Josh] Just gonna have to risk it.
Please don't split, please don't split.
Oh, my God.
[Josh] Don't know if it's gonna slide.
Oh, dear.
[Saku] Don't have steady hands.
Oh, I broke it.
[groaning] Oh.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
One minute.
I'm just going to try it.
Don't break.
[sniffles]
I just can't believe it.
[exhales]
-I've got something out.
-That's great. You did it.
I've got…
But it's better than it was, isn't it?
[Josh] Come on, Josh.
Oh, I just feel like the top
looks a bit cack.
[Cristy] Okay, just breathe.
[Dana] If it moves, it'll break.
[Matty] I don't know what I can do,
anything I do now will look random.
It looks beautiful,
but I broke a little bit.
[Tasha] Oh, my God.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your showstoppers.
[exhales]
Just don't think…
It just looks a bit like, I dunno.
-[Cristy] The whole thing cracked.
-No.
-And I got it done in two minutes to go.
-No, it's fine.
[Alison] It's time for the bakers'
showstopping floral desserts
to face judgement.
Tasha, would you like
to bring up your showstopper, please?
I love the look of this.
It's so professional.
I love the jelly on the top.
The line down there is not the best thing,
but you're always gonna get that,
there'll be a break.
-[Prue] And occasionally, jelly runs out.
-[Paul] A leakage. Yeah.
That jelly looks lovely.
It doesn't look too rubbery.
It looks really as if it's collapsing,
which is lovely.
[Noel] Wow.
Mmm, it's absolutely heavenly.
Thank you.
Raspberry and hibiscus,
that's the most delicious flavour.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] Really good elderflower.
The bitterness that you get
from the hibiscus
balances with everything else.
If you can manage to fit it all
in your mouth, and I have a large mouth,
you get all the flavours together,
which is what you wanted to achieve,
and end up with something beautiful.
Well done.
It's a triumph. Well done, Tasha.
Thank you.
[Paul] It's very pretty.
It's very pastel
which suits the tent beautifully.
Your flowers and your jelly work
is really beautiful.
[Paul] Distinctive lines.
-Distinctive colour.
-[Prue] Very good texture.
Just set, which is what you want.
[Saku] Thank you.
[spoon clatters]
The ginger is the overwhelming flavour.
I'm not getting much flavour
in anything else.
I mean, I'm hunting for anything.
[Prue] Is this raspberry?
That is hibiscus.
-Hmm.
-[Paul] Hmm.
It's so mild,
you need to carry a big punch in this
-to make it work.
-Okay.
All your textures are spot on,
but your flavours are lacking.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you, Saku.
[Prue] Thank you.
It's certainly imaginative.
[laughs]
It left the edges exposed
which I quite like.
-Do ya?
-That's where you are like an opera cake.
[Prue] Very nice, even layers.
I never thought I'd say this, but I think
there's actually too much floral.
-Okay.
-[Prue] It's very perfumed.
Mostly elderflower.
That's the strongest, isn't it?
Hmm, that's really sharp.
Probably too sharp for what this is.
I get the meadowsweet as well.
Bit like freshly cut grass.
-Yeah.
-It's got that flavour.
There is certainly a strong botanical feel
to this, which is what we wanted.
[Prue] Very good choux too.
Overall, you've done a decent job.
-Thanks.
-[Paul] Thanks.
-Well done.
-[Dan] Cheers.
Whether it's a showstopper, I'm not sure.
-Yeah.
-I'm not so sure.
The flowers would have been
better if you'd done a pile,
and then sort of cascaded it down.
Yeah, they're a little
like soldiers in a row.
Let's see what it's like inside.
Uh-huh.
[Alison] Ooh!
[Prue] You've got your layers
nicely separated.
Yeah, the lemon…
-Got elderflower with it?
-[Matty] Yeah.
[Paul] Not strong.
It doesn't quite meet the botanical brief.
One feels it's a lemon cake.
I think your custard layer
is too stodgy and a bit rubbery.
That's very rubbery.
It is delicious,
but it isn't a showstopper.
-Thank you. Cheers.
-Thank you.
[Noel and Alison] Well done.
[sighs]
It's beautiful.
Looks great.
Thank you.
It has split on the outside.
It looks very pretty.
I love the work here on the top.
Very skilful injecting.
-[Paul] Come on.
-[Prue] Wobble.
Look at that.
[Paul grunts]
[sighs]
[Paul] The setting of this is spot on.
You managed to get
each of the layers there
without too much rubber in each layer,
so they've held together just about.
The flavours are spot on.
[Prue] And I think the compote
is beautiful.
Great flavours, great textures,
overall look. Shame it's split, but--
-Needed a ribbon.
-You've done a great job.
-Well done.
-Lovely, thank you.
Dana, you've certainly got something
of a showstopper just in the box.
[Paul] Looks amazing.
Flowers are beautifully done,
but the main thing is the dessert.
[Paul] Let's have a quick look
inside this.
-[Alison] Oh, wow.
-[Prue] Wow, look at those.
[Paul] Pretty stark colours, them.
-I'm not sure I'm getting the floral.
-Okay.
[Paul] Not getting the rose.
-A bit of hibiscus.
-[Paul] Mmm.
The raspberry comes through
more than the hibiscus.
Yeah.
The sponge has dried out,
like it's been there for three days.
Because you put that
in the fridge for so long.
[Prue] Cake is pretty solid
and the layers are too thick.
Overall, your appearance is exceptional.
But is it style above substance?
Thank you.
Be honest, I… It was all going well,
everything was set…
-Stop.
-Okay.
[Paul] It's effective. I like the colour.
These are quite nice.
There's a couple of little splodges.
You've had issues with it.
I am getting strong strawberry
and a decent amount of tang
from the elderflower,
which is your saving grace
because it makes it floral.
The sponge is all right.
Setting, it's a bit messy, that's all.
Okay.
I feel sorry for you, because you
were nearly into something perfect.
But I think with your second attempt,
your chocolate ganache
is too much and too thick,
and the layers
are a bit all over the place.
It's still very delicious.
Thank God it's over. [laughs]
[Paul] I've seen people
throw stuff in the bin before.
I was determined
I wasn't gonna be one of 'em.
[Cristy laughs]
I'm relieved.
I'll take that any day over what
could've been an absolute nightmare.
[Dana] I do think
I'm in the bottom side of things.
But even if some of the inside fillings
weren't the best,
I'm beyond proud of it.
[Matty] I fell right at the last hurdle
in terms of making it look
like the showstopper it was meant to be.
They couldn't taste anything.
Look at my face for the last time,
I'm going home tonight.
[quacking]
So, Prue and Paul, Botanicals Week.
How do you think it went?
-Surprisingly well.
-It's actually been quite successful.
The bakes have all been pretty good.
When it comes to judging,
comes down to little things.
Who were the standout people for you?
Josh. The textures were right,
the flavours were terrific.
The whole thing was quite imaginative,
-beautifully executed.
-Hmm.
[Prue] I was blown away by Tasha's.
Tasha started well this week actually.
She didn't do too well
in the technical, she was 7th.
But she has bounced back in a big way.
So, it puts her in line for Star Baker.
Then you look at Cristy,
she had a bit of a mess up with this,
but it did taste good and it looked good.
-She carried on. I love that.
-[Paul] Never gave up.
I think three people struggled.
I think Matty struggled.
It wasn't quite polished enough
and finished and a bit simple.
But then you look at Dana.
The box was okay.
-I thought it was amazing.
-It was a showstopper,
-but the dessert had to be perfect.
-What it was all about.
-[Prue] The cake was too thick, a bit dry.
-[Alison] Yeah.
And then Saku.
-[Prue] Hardly any flavour.
-Such a shame.
But that's not like her either,
which is strange.
[Paul] It's gonna be tight
whoever we choose to go home today.
-It's only one today though, isn't it?
-Yeah, only one today.
Paul wants to send three people home.
[all laughing]
Well done, bakers,
you did fantastic in Botanicals Week.
I've got the great job this week
of announcing Star Baker.
And this week's Star Baker is…
Josh.
[all applauding]
[Cristy chuckles]
And unfortunately,
I've got the job that no one wants.
I've gotta say this has been
one of the hardest decisions
of the competition so far.
So, the baker leaving the tent today is…
Dana.
[Dana exhales]
Well done.
Oh, thank you.
-[Paul] Sorry, Dana. Wasn't your week.
-No, it's okay.
Feel I've smashed it, week six.
-[Dan] You've been amazing.
-Thanks.
And we'll miss you so much.
I'm just thinking of all the fun
I've had throughout the six weeks.
That's what I'm gonna remember.
Well done. Oh, my God, Josh. Well done.
You so deserve that.
Overwhelmed. I don't know what to say.
It's incredible.
Yeah, can't wait to tell my mum.
[Dan] You deserved that.
You've been knocking on the door,
brother, for ages. Well done.
-Got news to share with you.
-[Josh's mum on mobile] Yeah?
I'm Star Baker for this week.
-[Josh's mum screams] Yes! Star Baker!
-[laughs]
Oh, thank you so much. [chuckles]
Through, yeah.
Probably a little bit
by the skin of the teeth, but through.
-Oh, my beautiful girl. Hmm.
-[Dana chuckles]
Phew.
I know now, how I am going to ask
annual leave from my manager.
That's my worry. [laughs]
Tomorrow morning, email.
"Charlotte, I want more time off."
Charlotte will climb walls. [laughing]
[closing theme music playing]